après 30 ans de bons et loyaux services
et m6 vient de nous apprendre une
terrible nouvelle il n'y aura désormais
plus de téléfilms l'après-midi sur m6
[Musique]
et oui à cause d'audiences un peu
faiblarde et d'une concurrence de tf1
sur le même créneau les après-midis
téléfilm de m6 ont laissé place depuis
hier à des reportages sur les françaises
bienvenue dans un jour en doc votre
nouvelle émission de reportages et des
spectateurs peuvent donc dire adieu à
ses films aux répliques cultes les
plantes aromatiques c'est chouette
j'adore hossein de bagnols spectaculaire
mais pourquoi tu t'arrêtes la voiture
est en panne non
mais aussi à des scénarios parfois très
soul où j'ai quelque chose à vous faire
voir fermer les yeux tous les deux ok
mauvais
[Musique]
noir
mais est-ce que tu as trouvé cette photo
alors est-ce que le programme de doc
fonctionne mieux à fait les mêmes
audiences mais surtout ça coûte zéro
parce que c'est des rediffusions donc en
fait aujourd'hui les chaînes tout ce
qu'ils font c'est géré de la
décroissance et art qu'elles savent qui
a de moins en moins de monde devant la
télé donc elle se dit voilà on va faire
on va limiter la casse en audience et
dépenser un minimum d'argent c'est ce
qui se passe là et moi ce qui se fait
pas ce qui me fait peur avec tout ces
rapprochements m6 tf1 etc c'est qu'on a
trois quatre groupes qui vont détenir
toutes les chaînes je pense qu'on va
voir les mêmes programmes qui vont
passer 50 fois soirée mais rien n'y aura
qu'un groupe actif altis tf1 m6 et canal
et des télévisions alors quoi qu'en
pensent certains découvrent le père ni
couche il en pense quoi il en pense que
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'harmonie de
programmes s'était alors vous êtes pas
on met pas deux genres en face à france
télévisions c'était c'était exactement
la même chose moi je suis content je
suis plutôt pour l'harmonie de cible
c'est à dire que je pense qu'on
s'adresse pas forcément aux mêmes cibles
quand on parle de tf1 par exemple aider
mme this way et que en l'occurrence
idées à des publics sur les deux chaînes
qui sont des plumes différents donc je
suis pas forcément pour ça et à l'époque
à france télévisions se poser la
question de questions pour un champion
face à n'oubliez pas les paroles moi
j'avais soutenu le ca en disant que
c'était deux cibles différentes parce
que l'on pour un champion est très fort
sur les plus âgées et en l'occurrence il
avait décidé de permettre de jouer en
face voilà c'est un choix mais
effectivement je rejoins guillaume sur
le fait que vous y êtes allé chercher un
peu la concurrence de france télé qui
cartonne à sept ans et c'est faustine
bollaert je crois pas je suis pas
certaine moi je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise idée c'est le début de la fin
pour moi pour l'après midi dames 6 et
pas que des buts oui mais vous verrez
pourquoi à noël vous me direz que j'ai
raison parce que quand elle arrivera
vous savez que dès mi-octobre et
commence à nous donner
la mort ce sont des institutions chez
tf1 et chez m6 malheureusement pour pas
être en concurrence avec las les
remettre à noël mais non je suis sûr que
non ils vont laisser la faveur a tf1 on
va se taper encore de la merde parce que
malheureusement les séries documentary
dames 6 on n'est pas non plus dans du
netflix avec du inventing anas est
pourri ils veulent maintenir en tout cas
ça c'est vraiment leur premier concept
le raconter des histoires ça c'est leur
premier truc donc ils veulent raconter
l'histoire mais du réel donc ils en ont
marre un peu de ses fictions qui sont un
peu niais parce que caster s'ils se
retrouvent eux c'est du réel bah oui
c'est dur elle est sa manière à mieux ça
marche mieux regarder les scores
c'est pas vous faire passer pas mal à
958 mille corse mais non c'est pas ouf
quand on dit que c'est pas autorisé
parce que c'est pour vous les voiles
après midi quand on somnole devant sa
télé qu'on a fait ça c'est qu'ils
consomment énormément de télévision mais
moi je trouve que c'est fromage ou
dessert quoi c'est très très bien qu'on
ait le choix si ceux-ci des gens aiment
ce genre de téléfilm il faut choisir la
touche de deux cibles différent je
trouve l'harmonie toujours utile dans un
couple où elle était dans un couple
absolue pour moi